el Mediterráneo nuevamente se convirtió
en el lugar de la muerte para decenas de
migrantes luego de que una embarcación
que transportaba civiles de Afganistán
Irán Pakistán y otros países se
estrellara contra las rocas en las
costas cercanas a la localidad de
calabria dentro de las víctimas se
encontraban niños y al menos 80 personas
lograron sobrevivir La primera ministra
Georgia melone reaccionó la tragedia y
se comprometió a lidiar con la
inmigración irregular
la primera ministra Georgia expresa su
profundo dolor por las numerosas vidas
truncadas por los traficantes de seres
humanos el gobierno se ha comprometido a
prevenir las salidas y con ellas la
ocurrencia de estas tragedias y seguirá
haciéndolo ante todo exigiendo la máxima
cooperación de los estados de salida y
de origen
la Cruz Roja italiana auxilió a los
sobrevivientes de un nuevo caso que
revive la crisis migratoria en el
Mediterráneo un asunto a tratar para la
comisión Europea
estoy profundamente entristecida por el
Terrible naufragio frente a las costas
de calabria la pérdida resultante de
Vidas de migrantes inocentes es una
tragedia todos juntos debemos redoblar
nuestros esfuerzos En el pacto sobre
migración y asilo y en el plan de acción
sobre el Mediterráneo central la
situación de los migrantes se complicó
más luego de Que el parlamento italiano
aprobara el pasado jueves un decreto que
fija un nuevo procedimiento que
condiciona la labor de los barcos de
salvamento de migrantes a pesar del
rechazo de Naciones Unidas según el
proyecto de migrantes desaparecidos de
la ONU se registraron más de 17.000
muertes y desapariciones en el
Mediterráneo central desde 2014